depuis et ses terres au royaume uni avec
bharat panka mia expert en maladies
infectieuses à l'université c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir baratin cagna merci d'être avec
nous en direct pour vu de l'extérieur ce
soir l'om est pointée du doigt dans
cette fille notamment par donald trump
est ce qu'il ya des fautes commis selon
vous en tant que spécialiste par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé est
ce qu'il faudrait qu'elle revoie son
fonctionnement il faut être très prudent
looking up louer mais c'est la seule
institution qui surveille la santé et le
bien-être de beaucoup d'états membres
la confiance en le ms est nécessaire le
ms doit être soutenue de être en pleine
confiance
peut-être capable d'effectuer son
travail notamment dans les pays plus
pauvres les pays pauvres ont besoin de
l'om est bien plus que les pays riches
les pays occidentaux nous avons donc
besoin de la soutenir
et bien sûr il est très important de
tirer des enseignements de nos loudes
batteur action il faut voir comment
améliorer la situation et comment mieux
soutenir l'om est ce pour vous un
l'organisation mondiale de la santé à
gérer parfaitement cette crise il n'y a
rien à redire selon vos seuls le temps
de me dire ah ouais mais c'est une
organisation très large et des personnes
aimées par mois annoncé que cette crise
apparaît très bien avant l'organisation
gelé qualifiée de pandémie au moins deux
semaines avant l'om est ce donc
vous le voyez le ms est bien plus lente
dans sa réaction
mais il faut également savoir que le ms
ne peut faire son travail aussi bien que
les états membres laisse le faire le
problème est que msc que les états
membres protègent leurs positions
respectives
nous perdons donc au niveau de la
science il ya un peu plus de politique
dans les rouages de l' oms des états
membres défendent leurs intérêts leur
posture il serait mieux que des experts
des états membres qui ne serait pas
partiaux envers ses états membres
j'espère que je suis claire oui vous
êtes parfaitement clair et c'est
intéressant comme point de vue parce que
justement l'une des principales
critiques de donald trump c'est la
complaisance entre guillemets de l' oms
vis-à-vis notamment de la chine
est ce que vous vous êtes d'accord avec
ce postulat où vous ne partagez pas du
tout ce diagnostic eid soan
je ne pense pas cela je suis extrêmement
nôtre ce n'est pas une question de
complaisance envers quiconque
l'om est ce qu'on peut faire son travail
et que si la chine la forme de ces
problèmes
donc jusqu'à ce que la chine est dit
elle même est ce qu'un nouveau problème
était apparu alors le travail ne peut
pas commencer
c'est une organisation de santé mondiale
il ya beaucoup de commissions de comités
et la prise de décision est plus lente
de ce fait je souhaiterais que nous
redéfinissions la façon dont les comités
scientifiques sont gérées afin que les
décisions se fasse bien pu rapidement
afin de limiter les débats et la
consultation qui font perdre du temps
anouk et bien sûr l'om est ce doit être
financé correctement
afin d'avoir des bureaux compétents sur
le terrain alors il ya une critique qui
nous vient du secrétaire général de
l'onu dont dépend d'ailleurs l'om est ce
nous avons vu des expressions solidarité
mais très peu d'unités dans notre
réponse face à la coved 19 les pays ont
suivi des stratégies différentes parfois
contradictoires et nous en payons tous
le prix fort voici la déclaration
d'antonio guterres est ce aujourd'hui
est-ce que igad ça justement on ne paye
le prix fort dans cette gestion de
lakovic 19 par manque d'unité des pays
membres justement de dauphin nous avons
un des différences d'opinion il niveau
de la gestion de l'épidémie
les coréens du sud ont fait du très bon
travail ils l ont listé les contacte
alors que les etats-unis ont fait tout à
fait le contraire
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas un problème
pour les états unis et non pas à copier
ce qu'ils auraient dû faire à temps
alors même qu'il bénéficiait d'
avertissement très clair il donne donc
les pays asiatiques les chinois les
coréens les taiwan et les habitants de
singapour ont fait du très bon travail
très rapidement les européens l'italie
en tout cas a été prise de court et les
américains on est tout simplement décidé
qu'il ne fallait pas s'en soucier
effectivement nous avons besoin d'une
santé publique internationale qui
travaille dans l'unité qui décide d'un
plan sinon effectivement ce genre de
catastrophe se reproduira vous évoquez
nécessaire soutien financier l oms or il
se trouve que les etats-unis ont annoncé
vouloir arrêter de subventionner
l'organisation pour vous ça va avoir de
conséquences très graves des
conséquences très graves et clora bhl au
mieux d'une pandémie la pierre que la
planète est connue les états unis
décident pour une raison quelconque
c'est inexplicable d'arrêter de financer
l'om s c'est une leçon très importante
en tant que communauté mondiale devons
travailler de concert nous devons
permettre à aucun pays qu'il s'agisse de
la chine l'union européenne des etats
unis ou des pays d'amérique du sud
dicté le comportement et le financement
de l oms s'il n'y a plus de financement
le travail est impossible le ms ne peut
pas mener ce travail dans les pays les
plus pauvres à et donc la circulation du
virus en afrique reviendra sur le devant
de la scène et aura un impact sur les
pays européens et dans le reste du monde
donc il serait dans l'intérêt des états
unis de l'union européenne du japon et
de la chine ou de continuer à financer
le ms afin de limiter le nombre des cas
dans le monde entier
c'est dans leur propre intérêt
ma dernière question aujourd'hui lors de
l'assemblée annuelle 1 de l'om est ce la
chine s'est dite favorable à une enquête
sur l'origine de l'épidémie une fois
qu'elle sera enrayée on sait on rappelle
que donald trump accusent la chine
justement d'être à l'origine de cette
épidémie de l'avoir caché vous pensez
qu'on aura un jour la vérité sur ce qui
s'est vraiment passé notamment sur la
façon dont la chine a géré la crise du
cordat virus c'est un sujet très
important et il y a deux parties
la chine a géré la crise et l'origine
des nouveaux virus
c'est ce que j'appelle la prévention
mais on peut dépenser des millions afin
d'arrêter l'apparition de nouveaux virus
en changeant nos pratiques humaines
beaucoup de pratiques humaines par
exemple celle de chasser ou de capturer
des animaux sauvages de ce sans nourrir
ou alors un hameau de donner des
antibiotiques à des animaux qu'ils
engraissent plus rapidement et pour
accroître les profits sont des problèmes
causés par l'humanité qui existent dans
le monde entier notamment aux états unis
il faut mettre un terme par des
comportements nuisibles comme cela sinon
on passera des milliers de milliers de
milliards après l'étape de la prévention
merci bar à tapas en khâgne un expert en
maladies infectieuses à l'université
d'exeter d'avoir été avec nous pour vu
de l'extérieur ce soir